it might not feel like it now but soon
it will be time for kids to go back to
school so
it's time to talk about vaccines
mercedes checked in with the southwest
medical expert to learn more about the
subject
vaccinations are so important and i am
joined by
chelsea sandusky today with the
pediatrics division at southwest medical
and chelsea why is it so important for
us to vaccinate
vaccinations are vital um to provide
protective antibodies
before we become exposed to particular
diseases
it's always better to prevent diseases
rather than dealing with any
consequences
long-term sequelae or treatment after
having
suffered the disease has there been any
sort of a return
of preventable diseases absolutely
measles believe it or not was considered
an eradicated disease in 2000
whooping cough continues to have annual
cases throughout the united states and
these diseases are
highly preventable with the vaccine but
easily spread
via aerosolized droplets so some young
infants are too young to receive the
vaccinations
and some children may not be fully up to
date on their boosters for the
vaccinations based on their age so
that's why i heard immunity and we've
heard that word
herd immunity a lot recently but that's
why herd immunity is so
important let's talk about the
vaccinations that
children need what are we looking at
here children that will be entering into
preschool
kindergarten and seventh grade will have
standardized vaccinations that they
require
the dtap the polio mmr and varicella
will be required
for entrance into the preschool and
kindergarten programs
and then your tdap booster and
meningitis vaccinations
are required for seventh grade okay so
what are some of the risks that go with
skipping or delaying your child's
vaccinations or boosters
foregoing vaccinations altogether or
delaying vaccinations really opens up
that window of opportunity that your
child might become
exposed to one of these preventable
diseases
some vaccinations require up to two
weeks to have full antibody response
and then other vaccines even require
additional doses or boosters of the
vaccine to really have that tip-top
immunity
so delaying or foregoing vaccinations
really
you're kind of rolling the dice that
your child might be able to be exposed
and then of course negatively affected
if they contract the disease
now i'm a parent and what would you want
me
and other parents to know if we have
concerns about
bringing our kids in for appointments
with their pediatrician
what i would suggest to parents is
calling your pediatrician's office
and asking them you know do you have any
safety precautions any protocols we can
follow
a lot of times pediatric offices will be
able to give you a particular
date or time where the office may be
less busy
that way to ensure more social
distancing and ease any of those
pandemic concerns
but bringing those children in is really
important
southwest medical associates locations
across southern nevada
you can reach them and learn more about
them there's the phone number
702-877-5199 or go to
smalv.com